top 20 spéciales téléralité on vous la
fait un peu plus tôt parce qu'on voulait
voir tous les jeunes aussi voilà on
famille alors en numéro 20 vous vous
souvenez tous de la ferme célébrités et
parmi elles il y avait vincent mcdoom ce
que vous rappelez de vincent mcdoom dans
la ferme c'est super beau chant et très
philosophe vincent mcdoom ce jour-là il
attendait un signe divin et une vache
lui a apporté c'est notre vin numéro 20
de l'intégralité regard et je peux vous
dire qu'on a du très très lourd
regardez ça moi
je sais je fais de mon travail si je
mets plus les mêmes
[Musique]
à ce stade de jeu
est-ce que tu entres en 2010
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu veux
si vous lui donnez moi répond sans fin
ne fera jamais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
trois filles
c'est
[Musique]
m
lourdes mais quelle lourdeur sais pas où
sébastien bach donc j'étais toi qui
s'est passé lors j'ai fait j'ai repris
avec jean pierre foucault la ferme
célébrités en afrique cyril bravo mon
ben voilà juste comme ça cette émission
là aujourd'hui on pourrait plus
l'affairé que animaux par des gros
problèmes pour appliquer des problèmes
sur le studio parce qu'il y avait les
des poussins qui avait été un peu et b a
écrasé le stade c'est vrai c'est vrai
alors dans les marchés ya rios en 19e
position ya crime qui s'est posé une
question existentielle syli à la lune à
rio est ce qu'en france ils ont la même
l'une regarder certains manuels c'est du
très lourd face à rené malleville ça
c'est pour toi saronni sarrade père
regarde et savait qu'on avait la même
ligne pour tout le monde pas oui je
pense que tu imagines sérieusement sinon
la lune là comme en france ils ont aussi
juste que c'est décalé c'est tout il ya
deux jours avant et la nuit après c'est
tout mais on a toujours la même je me
dis mais sous de ma gueule c'est pas
possible
et non elle croit vraiment qu'il ya des
lunes moi je suis vous prouver qu'on a
pas qu'une lune ce que c'est
statistiquement impossible
ok d'accord ça avait plus génial de
l'histoire dont une à voir au 19ème
position
en tout cas il ya une lune qui ne bouge
jamais c'est bien celle de benjamin
castaldi qu au coach personnel ont
toujours en place
toujours à ça passe toujours à sa place
on passe en 18e position j'espère vous
êtes en famille vous nous regardez on va
parler d'émissions qui veut épouser mon
fils or certaines émissions que
j'adorais moi c'est donc des mères qui
présentaient leur fils un as des
prétendantes et il ya un candidat
michael il était pépère sur le canapé
avec sa famille il a vu des gâteaux sur
la table basse ils en mangent 1
le problème c'est que ce n'était pas des
gâteaux regardez ces 18e manière dont on
discute et d'avoir mangé ces trucs on va
quand même en discuter au niveau du
physique non c'est pas le physique en
fait c'est je pense que c'est une fille
qui sera s'occuper de michael qui est
pas superficielle qui sévit j imagine il
a mangé la bouche et je crois que c'est
des macarons on dit bien c'est bon mais
s'y colle aux dents il ya peu de temps à
réagir quand même ouais c'est vrai ils
le mangent bien il marche un peu un en
17e position c'était dans le loft 2
benjamin castaldi vous y étiez alors ça
c'est moi qui l'animé ça c'est la sortie
de l' aventure d'afida turner au moment
où elle sort elle mais le plus gros vent
de l'histoire de la télé à séverine
ferrer séverine ferrer a faisait quoi
dans l'émission déjà séverine benjamins
à écouter ça ne va pas marquer mais elle
devait faire les sorties de les sortir
candidats de la maison et c'est çà et là
et rien manquer à l'été 2010 ça fait du
buzz quoi des matrices on voit vous
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
coin de son public déjà benjamin
mais on se rend pas compte mais quand il
sortait du loft
on avait l'impression est franchement
mais sans rigoler c'était c'était jason
statham c'est un truc sur le 2 sur le 2
sur les deux beaucoup moins que sur le 1
re nettement déjà mais quand on est
descendu un peu quand même mais ce qui
est marrant c'est que afida quand elle
est sortie elle pour c'est vraiment
qu'elle était devenue une énorme star
planétaire et est en fait elle est bien
bien bien fêter avant de sortir de la
maison allait continuer après on les
loger dans un très bel dans un très bel
hôtel pour qu'ils puissent comme ça pour
descendre en pression et quand elle est
arrivée dans ce palace 5 étoiles à la
pousser la porte
elle a fait une énorme une énorme gerbe
qui s'est étalée bien partout c'était
très sympa très bien bravo merci
benjamin des anecdotes toujours plus
innovantes mais au bout des doigts
sauvait quand même on est on est en 16e
position
pendant un moment sur nrj12 y avait
giuseppe ristorante ce que vous a
rappelé de sa cité un cow-boy axa fait
giuseppe qui était un candidat de qui
veut épouser mon fils qui ouvrait un
resto et il est avec sa mère qui était
très très extravagante
sauf que quand elle fait du ses goûts et
c'est pas la même regardez oussekine à
la maman
[Musique]
voilà je vous proposais droite
moi
waaa ou bouthaïna pire c'est qu'on
attend ça tout le match et on se tient
pas ses oreilles à un moment ça tombe
dès la tendre aussi chez vous voilà
c'est du méreau 16 du top 20 de la
téléralité en 15e position il ya une
discussion lunaire qu'on a mis en 15e
position du top 20 télé réalité c'était
dans les anges entre analyse et martic
alors ce dock candidate des anges de la
télé réalité
l'une à reprocher à l'autre de ne pas
avoir d' humour mais comment elle écrit
humour
regardez ça ça te n'ont pas cessé il
faudrait poser la question ben moi je
l'aimais bien après
un peu poussé vers la sortie voilà vous
savez tous que c'était une chose si
j'avais bien soit 0,13 à chacune en fait
je connais you were en plus on lui a
fait de la demande et des piétons n'est
pas torres
elle aurait pu le dire avant la
tranquille publier des plaies et moi uem
aux humeurs non mais c'est bien à quoi
un an passé en troisième position dans
la star ac 2 il ya vingt élèves plutôt
sympathique mais on sait pas ce qu'il
faisait là tout ce qui était chants et
rythmes ce n'était pas son truc c'est
georges alain là il chantait la friture
absent dans la misère fois c'est un
quatorzième position
on ne sait pas comment ça a pu passer
dans la star academy ça à chaque fois on
se pose la question
regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il indiqué
là bas
ap
[Musique]
et
j'avais dit m
il s'en fout totalement georges est rien
il est venu chez nous tiens je vais le
faire à mon avis ne voulait pas du tout
chanter cette chanson je pense que c'est
surtout ça le truc et qu'on l'a forcé à
chanter saturation oui j'ai rallié vous
ai dit un truc oui oui mais kate est
marrant chez georges à l'époque se
souvient c'est que malgré tout il avait
vraiment une bonne cote qu'il y avait un
côté mauvais garçon des mêmes les
professeurs comme armande altaï rousseau
et qui l'adoré adoré vraiment le
préserver il est dans un petit cocon et
pourtant il est là il n'était pas
exceptionnel mais il avait vraiment
beaucoup de charisme déjà enfin moi je
trouvais à l'époque en tout cas bon le
qui fait en 13e position
il sait pas qui c'est quelque chose dans
secret story 10 d'incroyables en plein
direct
ils ont révélé que mélanie taille et
tout le monde dans leur dos évidemment
ça plaît pas à nice qui la menacent de
lui mettre dans quelque chose dans les
fesses alors je vous parle de gens que
vous ne connaissez peut-être pas c'est
donc mélanie c'est une candidate elle
était avec anaïs elle paye tout le monde
est là il ya une autre candidate qui lui
dit qui la menacent de lui mettre
quelque chose dans les fesses vous allez
me dire
curieuse méthode et vous aurez raison
ben ouais mais j'ai pas tu te tue pas
normale et un coup d'argent quatre ans
vaincu la vie nos nerfs 4 c'est facile à
coacher voilà c'est c'est sa part après
il faut pas mettre des choses comme ça
hein je vous dis la position en boivent
c'est en deuxième position va voir une
image qu'on a rarement reçu c'était
pendant la première star ac et nikos
pendant le prime
lisez la liste des courses des élèves et
celle de jean pascal lacoste qui nous
rejoint les prochaines qu'on embrasse
qui nous regardent tous les soirs et
complètement improbable ça c'est une
image qu'on a très peu revu ses
douzièmes des images de télé réalité
regardez ça c'est ouf et jean pascal
voilà ta liste de courses tu me la
donnera aussi avant d'intégrer des
missions à plat
j'ai dans mes mains une liste réaliste
pour les courses ce qu' ils ont
effectivement besoin d'un certain nombre
de choses qui n'ont pas dans le château
il ya une poupée gonflable
il ya aussi la vôtre mais moi pardonnez
moi mais il ya une foufoune en plastique
avec jean-pascal une poupée gonflable
composants plastiques n'importe quoi oui
je passe la main
oui juste pour info avant au début la
téléréalité voulait absolument que les
candidats se fassent à manger qui une
gestion des cours et pâtes etc du frigo
ça a été très vite abandonnées parce que
ça faisait chier tout le monde je vous
le dis c'était une tana salle afin d'en
renvoyer le restaurant les matches aller
livraison c'était ça ma vie est un
voyage pour benjamin qui connaît bien le
truc et qu'il vous donne des infos en
11e position de notre top 20 téléralité
c'est dans les marseillais il y avait
une épreuve c'était de manger des
testicules de mouton
tout le monde est dégoûté sauf que
jessica c'est un autre problème qui
angoisse regardez c'est bizarre comme
question mais bon etc voilà c'est sa
façon de penser regarde
voici des testicules de mouton c'est pas
une vie gallo je mange pas de viande
assez palladium
c'est pas gagné testostérone dans
l'avion et là c'en est vraiment trop
pour moi je ne peux pas manger des
couronnaises de mon temps c'est pas
possible ça me dégoûte c'est l'arrière
les petits spermatozoïdes s'il en est
les bébés des moutons dps dû aller bébé
moutons el fani rigoler à les ondes en
dixième position et c'est une embrouille
elle est magnifique c'était dans des
couples parfait c'est entre deux
candidats
ilan et sarah à lui a sorti une insulte
je vous jure je n'avais pas entendu
cette insulte depuis août 1935
regardez
un peu surpris même venant de lui qu'ils
puissent se permettre d'aller aussi loin
dans ses propos pour qu'il pourrait
jouer je consultais d'insultés si un
clochard copains comme toi grocam toi si
tu as des anges qu'il faut pas m'énerver
c'est que c'est c'est que c'est faux
faux faux pas m'énerver
c'est magnifique clampins sentence est
atypique là on part on rentre dans le
top 10 si on est à la 9e position qui se
rappelle de mickaël vendetta
mickaël vendetta mois à la géographie
tude bat benjamin tu l'a connu ah bah
moi il était dans la ferme justement en
afrique
ouais c'est ça et d'ailleurs julien et
j'aurai un scoop à vous donner tir juste
après et bien passé alors c'est quoi
mickaël vendetta il était candidat donc
dans la ferme célébrités c'était quand
même un petit arba même si on l'aimé
bien c'est vrai que voilà il faisait des
coups de fils et il ya david usher bekir
l'heureuse qui recevait la visite de sa
femme dans la ferme célébrités et
mickaël vendetta la kiffe pas de ouf
regardez
[Musique]
hébron
je pense que sa femme
je la connais pas je peux pas je peux
pas juger c'est vrai que je peux pas
donner une opinion sur vesle moi tout ce
que je sais c'est que j'ai mieux
enfin j'ai mieux c'est à dire que je
peux largement avoir mieux quoi inventé
le terme de bogossitude et j'embrasse
également david charvet si si nous
regarde qui inquiète un pote
voilà que je connais bien je leur ai dit
oui c'est même lui qui a remporté
d'ailleurs les démissions il a gagné et
pour un croc en fait l'aller la
production et la chaîne n'aimait pas du
tout le personnage au début et m'a
demandé de le recadrer
vous avez fait en direct et c'est le jeu
les sorties vaut mieux être un has been
qu'un never been aller en fait qu'en
amérique etc en effet ça et qui est
devenu évidemment populaire qui on a
compris qu'elle ait gagné on m'a
reproché de l'avoir engueuler et on m'a
remis les propos sur mon dos alors
c'était en fait on avait demandé
maintenant je le redis je le dis
maintenant pour vous n'avez jamais c'est
la chaîne
c'est la chaîne qui vous l'avez dit vous
voyez benjamin pollack a bien fait son
travail bravo mon benji en huitième
position salah les magnifiques c'était
une embrouille dans secretstory 4 entre
barbara et tania tania 71 ans
franchement elle nous régale y est tania
quand elle s'énerve
elle sort la boîte à fuck regard des
huitièmes un truc contre moi depuis le
début je sais pas ce que je fais et je
les joue en tout 90 90
c'est la fin de l'univers bien leur
métier d'abord mon petit frère et l'ipad
chacun trois ans barbara est une petite
greluche capricieuse je pense que c'est
une fille qui n'a pas beaucoup de
consistance pour moi c'est une coquille
vide c'est tout barbara je te sors la
machine à feu j'avais jamais vu ça s'est
passé où la vue est magnifique on est
dans le top 20 pc à la réalité et on
passe à la septième position c'est une
image que j'avais jamais vu moi c'est
dans la ferme célébrités il y avait
farid un ancien champion de boxe à un
moment donné farid khider
voilà farid voilà un moment donné le mec
est seul il se prend pour james bond il
dégaine ses doigts comme un pistolet est
là le coup part c'est pas james bond
c'est james prout
c'est le digne descendant de benjamin
castaldi regarde
[Musique]
oh
c'était pas farid khider c'est un autre
c'est farid ouais alors ça c'est
magnifique ça parce que moi tu le savais
ça ou pas tu l'avais vu ça ce que tu
étais lorsque j'ai regardé quotidien
juste pour info encore ses missions
avait démarré très fort pour le kick off
le premier numéro en effet pas 7
millions et on est divisé par deux
heures durant sans une semaine si bien
voir relégué à près à 22h30 parce
qu'évidemment ça a été un faux seins
faux épouvantable et pour l'anecdote
plus d'infos qui vous fait rigoler il ya
évidemment réunion de crise avec les
producteurs ça marchait pas du tout et
le patron de tf1 d'époque a dit elle est
la patronne de nîmes et expliquez moi
pourquoi j'ai acheté ce programme 20
millions d'euros pour faire en afrique
elle aurait pu le faire at war et merci
d'accord va très bien c'était qu'il
patron de tf1 c'est un gars que je
connais bien qui travaille et qui en
même temps il beaucoup c'est store
d'accord d'accord probable sixième
position il ya une télé ralité en
angleterre qui s'appelle georges
bischoff
c'est le même principe que celles en
france il ya une nana complètement
déchiré qui d'un coup a confondu le
parquet du salon avec des toilettes
regardez ça c'est 6e j'avais jamais vu
cette vidéo
ces voix là regardez ne faites pas ça
chez vous regarde à temps
qu'est ce qu'elle fout suite démoli non
chlorée
c'est pas
mais qu'est-ce que chloé est en train de
faire chloé noms tels fait caca c'est du
caca boulot et a fait caca
donc l'eau et des cônes ou quoi elles
viennent chien une pépites de chocolat
par terre on crée des ouais ouais ouais
ouais c'est quelque chose allait chéri
oui valérie et pour info en fait john
johnny shore ou en angleterre il ya la
passion américaine qui s'appelle georges
essor est en fait le principe c'est
plutôt trash c'est une bande de jeunes
qu'on met dans une maison et là pour le
coup c'est pas comme en france ni par
exemple marseille et on peut dire que
ces crashs lasser les vols mais fois
vingt fois cent fois mille et le béton
concert c'est d'y aller on est tous
complètement la production les pouces et
il faut qu'il soit le plus trash
possible place opposant qu'elle va
écouter ben là c'est en tout cas c'est
réussi on va passer en cinquième
position c'est un extrait du loft 2
c'est magique c'est kamel km qui était
très très drôle de regard de il apprend
à une autre candidat là une autre
candidate la date de l'indépendance de
l'algérie
il lui fait répéter 20 fois on se dit
c'est bon normalement je pense qu'elle a
bien en tête
et ben non regardez les ongles
assassinats de john et de à dépendre de
guerre d'algérie aux dépens de l'algérie
indépendante 62 à tripoli de l'algérie
qui ne sont pas fans de harry potter
c'est l'algérie est bien un
c'est l'indépendance jerry elle s'est
faite en quelle année 63 ans et une
seconde après la saisine à aller on va
parler on va passer au numéro 4 c'est un
autre candidat de télé réalité qui a eu
des soucis en plus aujourd'hui c'est
eddy le gars il te sort des pépites
on vous a fait une petite compil des 10
en plus il a fait parler de lui
aujourd'hui tristement parler lui
regarde numéro car ici la voix et dit ne
bouge pas qui a peint la joconde 5 kg a
dit je pense donc je suis guy de
maupassant victor hugo c'est pas un
succès peut-être chose à espérer non
plus aux appels l'acteur l'habitant vers
la gare là c'était bray des cartes à des
cartes mais est inconnu je les écarte le
quand il y en a des milliers
comment se prénomme les trois mages aux
cadets 1
mais que tu rapport aux les rois mages
en galilée la li na li na mélanger
perché comme les rois mages ou gagny
décroît hilton hotel et le galilée et au
garrick ohlsson hôtel le gain le ganil
et bonjour je l'accueille bon soir à
léon pas on passe aux trois premiers et
comment dans ce top ne pas parler de mon
incroyable fiancé
c'était exceptionnel c'est une scène
culte c'est quand laurent ournac saute
dans le jacuzzi vous rappelez leur
écrasent le français oui à y croire elle
fait croire donc à ses parents à toute
sa famille qu'elle a un nouveau fiancé
qui voit là dégueulasse et qui était
joué extrêmement bien par laurent ournac
c'était vraiment exceptionnel ça
regardez et sa prétendante donc la peau
vaseline qui va devenir sa femme était
dépité regardez ça c'est numéro trois
c'est extraordinaire ça
j'ai l'honneur de vous présenter le
votre fiancée
c'est dur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'un jeu autour des règles de l'entente
[Musique]
ça c'était génial c'était génial
oui oui j'aimerais deuxième partie de
soirée
les scores étaient hallucinants plus de
12 millions à 22h37 s'était jamais vu on
sera plus jamais incroyable mais qui
étaient ces belles jamais c'est
l'émission de télé réalité que j'ai le
plus régalé je vais intégrer des
toujours comme aujourd'hui cassés dès le
20 août avec celle des messieurs à
s'essayer à ce débat vraiment des
grosses grosses bah allez numéro deux
c'est dans les anges
11 il y avait vivian garçon sympathique
et déconneur il soit poil pour faire un
petit délire dans l'eau mais ce qui se
passe est complètement fou ces numéros
de la télé-réalité regardez c'est très
fort le plus loin possible mais les
malades
[Musique]
jai passage être à poil
oui moi je vais le tracé ronaldo lui est
impossible donc j'y vais
ce à quoi
[Musique]
alors ils ont ils ont cassé le cul cul
je n'ai pas de céder ou si c'est eux
mais bon ça va on aurait pu le voir on
aurait pu voilà je pense que c'est le
shérif là oui je pense que oui je pense
que c'est du temps mais dès qu en numéro
1 en numéro 1 on a décidé de vous mettre
greg le millionnaire rappelé degré
similaire avec ma avec marjolaine qui
était exceptionnel marjolaine sur le
partout ouais ben au délire l'excès et
le mec est en roue libre
regardez il a oublié qu'il était filmé
c'est très dur regarde
[Musique]
voilà
quand
[Musique]
j'ai vraiment apprécié son amère
grâce à toi que je suis là je suis sûr
partout
je suis dur par tous là
[Musique]
c'est durant ces deux jours tous les
sens du terme
hu est magnifique je suis dur de partout
c'est du grand greg voilà les numéros 1
est lui vraiment c'était une cité du
très lourd et benjamins terminent 1 fois
nous donner à nos téléspectateurs on
apprend des choses dans l'émission en
voyant les tops 20 téléralité géraldine
juste avant oui magie wave ou cyril qui
étreint pas aux producteurs et j'imagine
que producteur c'est se projeter
imaginer qu est-ce que ce sera la télé
dans six mois compte tenu du contexte là
et finalement quand on voit cette télé
réalité on s'aperçoit que fait céder et
beaucoup d'émissions d'enfermement et
donc en fait de près confinement est ce
que vous pensez qu'il va y avoir une
sorte de recrudescence de ce genre de
programme à nouveau alors qu'on pensait
que c'était mort et finalement ça va
être leur retour moi moi j'y crois pas
du tout moi je pense qu'au contraire je
pense qu'au contraire il va avoir
justement une envie de divertissement
une rémission dans la rue bref voilà je
suis en train d'errer d'essayer de
penser aussi même un immense jeu dans la
rue voilà je vous dis moi je pense qu'au
contraire je pense qu'on va avoir envié
sortir on va avoir envie de céder on a
environ rebord envie de divertissement
je sais qu'en ce moment les chaînes
d'info loin cartonne je sais qu'en ce
moment les émission d'info cartonne mais
je pense que si une fois que ce sera
tout sera rentré dans l'ordre et
j'espère que ça va aller vite et
j'espère que tout rentrera dans l'ordre
je pense que les gens vont avoir envie
vraiment deux divertissements et vont
délaisser fortement les chaînes d'info
et d émission d'info après c'est que mon
avis mais c'est ce que je pense qu'il y
aura un après où vraiment les gens et
mondial mine de rien aujourd'hui c'est
vrai que c'est hypnotique à me regarder
les chaînes d'info de regarder ce qui se
passe ils vous disent dix fois la même
chose en une minute mais on regarde et
e'lara ils disent la même chose que pour
une info ils vous font 24 heures donc
avec une info il tourne toute la journée
et voilà est il du monde mais c'est vrai
pour une avant ils vous font 24 heures
il ya des émissions aussi d'infos qui
tirent là dessus et qui font voilà d une
heure une heure et demie d'info sur une
info je pense qu'à un moment il va avoir
un petit ras-le-bol des téléspectateurs
ils vont vouloir s' il ya déjà un
divertissement et non non non les là en
ce moment dans les chaînes d'info qui
sont au top et les les jt n'ont jamais
aussi bien marché c'est un énorme carton